>> IT IS TIME FOR GENDER BENDER
BEAUTY PAGEANT.
THERE'S A WEB SITE CALLED
WORTHATHOUSAND.COM KNOWN FOR
USER GENERATED CONTEST.
RECENTLY THEY HAD A CONTEST FOR
PEOPLE WHO PHOTOSHOPPED MALE
CELEBRITIES AS LADYS.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU TWO MALE
ACTORS AND FOR 250 POINTS YOU
HAVE TO TELL ME WHICH MAN-LADY
THE WEB SITE SAID WAS THE
PRETTIEST.
HERE'S THE FIRST ONE...
>> IS NEITHER AN OPTION?
>> DOUG?
>> MATT DAMON IS PRETTIER?
>> NO, KEVIN SPACEY WAS WAY
PRETTIER THERE?
>> KEVIN SPACEY WAS WAY
PRETTIER.
>> VERY CREEPY BLOND.
>> THEY'RE BOTH AMERICAN
BEAUTIES.
>> NICE.
OH, THAT WAS GOOD.
I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS FOR THAT.
OKAY--
>> I HAVE TO ASK A QUESTION--
HOW IS YOUR REACTION SO
( BLEEP ) FAST?
IT'S CRAZY!
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW I DO IT.
( LAUGHTER )
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
>> HERE'S THE NEXT ONE.
DO YOU LIKE JACKIE BLACK OR
SHAWNA CONNERY.
YEAH, DOUG?
>> JACKIE BLACK IS PRETTIER.
>> ACTUALLY, THE THING SAID
SHAWNA CONNERY.
>> RECOUNT!
RECOUNT!
>> A MUSTACHE ISN'T PRETTY?
>> THAT REALLY IS NOT SAYING MY
WHOLE WORLD VIEW OF WOMEN RIGHT
NOW.
>> THEN WE PLAYED AROUND WITH
YOU GUYS.
PAULA SCHEER OR DOUGINA BENSON?
TOM LENNON?
>> HERE'S MY THING EYE FEEL LIKE
PAULINE-- SCHEER IS SORT OF
UNAPPROACHABLE, LIKE GWYNETH
PALTROW.
DOUGED LA.
>> DOUGINA.
>> DOUGINA BENSON I FEEL LIKE I
COULD GET TO THIRD BASE.
>> DOUGINA LOOKS LIKE A POP
STAR.
>> LOOKS LIKE KATY PERRY.
I'M GOING WITH DOUG.
>> THAT'S NOT ANSWER.
PAULA SCHEER WAS THE ONE.
>> REST ASSURED I WILL GO TO
THIRD BASE WITH YOU.
>> I LIKE THAT YOU PICKED DOUG
BECAUSE YOU THOUGHT HE'D BE
EASIER TO ( BLEEP ).
>> WELCOME TO MY LIFE IN THE
90s!
>> OKAY, THIS ONE IS FUN.
THIS ONE IS FUN.
TOMASINA LEPON OR CHRISTINA
HARDWICK?
OKAY, FIRST OF ALL, FIRST OF
ALL, FIRST OF ALL, TOM, YOU HAVE
SOME SWEET TITS.
>> I THOUGHT YOU HOOLED A
McCALL YOU CULKIN
AFTER-PICTURE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, DOUG?
>> AFTER WHAT?
>> AFTER YESTERDAY.
>> AFTER STARRING IN "RUN, LOCAL
ARUN."
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, TOM OR ME?
>> COME ON, YOU KNOW IT'S ME.
>> I'M GOING TO GO CAN TOMEDZ
ASINA.
>> YES, TOMASINA LENNON.
COMPLETELY IGNORED THE MUSTACHE.
>> WHICH IS SOMETHING I SAY